and we thank you for joining us on 8
news now i'm brian loftis and i'm denise
valdez 11
hours since this ordeal began the
freeway is back open
but there's still a lot of unanswered
questions about exactly what happened
and why we want to start tonight with a
check on how that trooper is doing for
that we go straight to orco mana
he is live outside of umc tonight with
more orco
well brian and denise that nhp trooper
is fighting for his life tonight
here at umc he was critically injured
during this afternoon's car chase turned
shooting on the i
one i-15 going through the windshield of
the suspect's car
witnesses tell us how it all unfolded
a chaotic car chase on the i-15 tuesday
afternoon leading to a series of
shocking events
this viewer video shows the female
suspect of an alleged carjacking
speeding away from nevada highway patrol
oh man it was crazy milton burns tells
me he saw everything unfold he says a
trooper threw spikes on the interstate
to slow the woman down
a local public safety officer's union
says that's when the woman hit the
trooper causing him to go head
first through her windshield that was
the craziest part of it all just
watching
half of a body out of a windshield just
being like
you know like a rag dog just going back
and forth
other troopers then forced the car into
a spin finally stopping her oh my god
they
shooting burns says troopers fired 20 to
25 shots at the woman the union tells 8
news now officers believed she was
reaching for a trooper's gun
she died at the scene
the helicopter arrived a short time
later and the injured trooper was taken
to umc
where he's currently in critical
condition his family and several nhp
colleagues
coming to the hospital to show their
support we're like a family
and when one of us is
hurt and while
out there trying trying to do their job
we all feel it
the incident causing a major backup on
the i-15 in both directions one of the
first drivers stopped at the scene was
stuck for close to half an hour
but commends law enforcement for their
swift action they did a fabulous job in
a matter of two or three minutes
of getting the whole area secure and
shut down the highway
now well wishes are pouring in for the
officer involved
i pray for him that was a terrible thing
no one deserves that
again the trooper is in critical
condition but is stable right now
sources tell us he will be identified
tomorrow morning
reporting live from umc tonight orca
mana 8 news now